[Musica]
è la più antica nella tematica
definizione la filosofia nasce dallo
stupore e io voglio condividere qui con
voi stasera il mio personale stupore
filosofico c'è il modo in cui sono
cambiati in cui stanno cambiando le
nostre relazioni nell'età digitale c'è
una cosa in particolare che in
particolare mi colpisce cioè
l'impressione che tanti di noi così
tanti di noi sottovalutiamo le
conseguenze delle nostre parole e delle
nostre azioni sul web
facciamoci caso è un'esperienza
quotidiana
pubblichiamo un commento su facebook e
scateniamo guerre civili
pubblichiamo una storia su instagram e
ci facciamo lasciare dei nostri partner
con i peggiori insulti
mandiamo degli sms riservatissimi e gli
screenshot fanno il giro del mondo ma
quello che colpisce in particolare è la
reazione di sorpresa che si determina
subito dopo quella sorpresa come a dire
oddio non mi sarei mai aspettato che un
messaggio potenzialmente accessibile
alcune milioni di persone potesse essere
eletto dal mio vicino di casa o dal mio
collega di lavoro è la sorpresa a volte
vuol dire una e una sola cosa cioè che
non c'è coerenza tra le previsioni e le
conseguenze delle nostre azioni che c'è
un'asimmetria tra le intenzioni e le
conseguenze questo è dovuto
principalmente a due ordini di motivi
c'è un aspetto quantitativo cioè il
fatto che sui social noi parliamo sempre
come se fossimo davanti a 23 persone al
limite una piccola folla una pizzata con
amici e d'improvviso ci rendiamo conto
che alcune migliaia di persone erano lì
dietro l'angolo
ad ascoltare a origliare le nostre
parole
l'orizzonte degli eventi si è ampliato
enormemente si è ampliato enormemente la
sfera delle responsabilità morali delle
nostre azioni e del motivo per cui siamo
costantemente esposti al rischio della
famosa del famoso battito d'ali di una
farfalla
quella che provocano tempesta ma non
dall'altra parte dell'oceano ma qui
dietro l'angolo a volte dentro casa
nostra
e poi c'è un aspetto qualitativo su cui
vorrei soffermarmi sul fatto che non è
le interazioni quotidiane
andiamo spesso così spesso col pilota
automatico perché perché nel corso
dell'evoluzione nei millenni abbiamo
affinato delle tecniche sofisticatissime
di gestione delle relazioni una serie di
azioni reazioni e interazioni che
semplicemente svolgiamo col pilota
automatico che sono quelle che ci
permettono di gestire le nostre
interazioni personali di persone invece
proviamo a immaginare con gli occhi
della relazione sociale tradizionale una
delle tipiche interazioni digitali
siamo un pomeriggio siamo sul divano
l'aria condizionata accesa fuori fa
caldo non abbiamo neanche voglia di
uscire poi uscire per andare dove
abbiamo davanti uno schermo e in questo
schermo ci siamo bombardati da immagini
di perfezione di feste da immagini di
festa in riva al mare di feste sul
fester sullo yacht e aforismi che ci
invitano essere irripetibili a essere
unici a vivere una volta sola ad essere
inimitabili
e questa una condizione particolare
questa è la condizione particolare
perché siamo soli
e come se fossimo soli in mezzo alla
folla
siamo solo in mezzo alla folla riusciamo
neanche a spiegarci il senso di questa
solitudine perché la valanga di immagini
che riceviamo cir ha come l'impressione
di essere in mezzo a questa folla e la
solitudine da che mondo è mondo provoca
diciamo rende più severi i nostri
giudici giudizi ci rende meno indulgenti
ci rende diciamo meno indulgenti nei con
del giudizio nei confronti degli altri è
la prima cosa che facciamo in questi
casi quello che facciamo insomma per
scaricare la tensione è quello di
scaricarla sulla sulla tastiera sulla
versione dell'iphone o del computer è
questa quindi una situazione particolare
questa che vediamo perché se allarghiamo
un poco l'orizzonte e guardiamo appunto
da una distanza un po più ampia ci
rendiamo conto che in questo momento noi
siamo di fronte a uno scontro
tra mondi da un lato il mondo delle
relazioni sociali tradizionali con tutto
questo carico evolutivo affinato tutte
queste cose che siamo abituati a fare
col pilota automatico e dall'altro lato
invece il mondo delle interazioni
digitali questo mondo nuovo di cui
stiamo scoprendo adesso le regole che
sono profondamente diverse da quella cui
siamo abituati a cui non siamo ancora
abituati
di solito a questo punto ci si schiera
da una delle due parti da un lato chi si
schiera dal lato delle relazioni sociali
tradizionali come si stava bene senza
facebook e senza instagram
anzi per favore torniamo alla macchina
da scrivere dall'altro lato i profeti
del digitale quelli che finalmente siamo
tutti connessi finalmente 5 gradi di
connessione possiamo tutti incontrarci
ecco io credo che ci sia una terza via
e questa è l'idea che voglio condividere
con voi stasera
facciamoci caso non si è mai parlato
così tanto di empatia intelligenza
emotiva intelligenza relazionale
capacità relazionali capacità di stare
in gruppo capacità di leggere i contesti
è come se avessimo scoperto
all'improvviso tutto quello che c'è di
sottointeso dietro le relazioni come se
all'improvviso questo scontro tra mondi
avesse portato alla superficie l'iceberg
su cui si basano le relazioni sociali
tradizionali quegli elementi di silenzio
di attenzione e di vicinanza di pazienza
di comprensione di cui sono fatte le
relazioni e questo credo è un'occasione
straordinaria un'occasione straordinaria
perché abbiamo una nuova consapevolezza
una consapevolezza basata su un bisogno
profondo sulla esigenza profonda perché
abbiamo scoperto finalmente che le vere
relazioni non sono quelle a portata di
click e quindi una fase straordinaria
per costruire sopra questo iceberg una
nuova idea di educazione umanistica la
nuova idea di dialogo di confronto di
vicinanza un'idea di educazione in cui
non si tratta semplicemente di
condividere parole di condividere
immagini ma anche di condividere la
passione per l'apprendimento condividere
la necessità di
appunto avere un tessuto comune in cui
confrontarsi scambiarsi opinioni
scambiarsi idee e dare e dare e chiedere
argomentazioni e non necessariamente
pensare che chi non la pensa come noi è
nemico o complice di un complotto è una
bella e straordinaria per immaginare
quindi ciascuno di noi nel nostro
piccolo nel nostro contesto di
reimmaginare lidia l'educazione nei
luoghi fisici di incontro nei luoghi
fisici di incontro e di educazione come
le scuole le università i collegi
l'occasione per promuovere di nuovo
questo senso di educazione umanistica
questa idea l'idea che fondamentalmente
educazione e senza un discorso sia un
dialogo sia un confronto tra persone
fisiche sia un confronto diretto
non è un'idea nuova se vogliamo è
sostanzialmente l'idea più antica di
educazione di insegnamento e di
filosofia non non è nuova ma soprattutto
adesso davanti al mondo digitale a
questo mondo nuovo nel quale si
affacciamo vale sempre la pena
riportarla in superficie
e vero la pena riportare in superficie
perché mi sembra fondamentalmente che
sia anche l'unica idea che qui oggi ci
permette di restare umani e umanisti
nell'età digitale
[Applauso]
[Musica]